[Music]  our Lord said to them go ye into the  whole world and preach the gospel to  every living creature  Ferrara is lost to us he denounced God  in public and surrendered the faith  that's not possible  father Ferreira risked his life to  spread our faith all over Japan it seems  to me that our mission here is more  urgent than ever we must go on fine  father Ferreira this is in your heart  stand both of you  then I must trust God as put it down the  moment you set foot in that country you  step into high danger  [Music]  the price for your glory their suffering  it's too treacherous we asked for this  mission  [Music]  I become lost  am I just break through silence  [Music]  but I think it's time we're looking at  the first proof of life beyond Earth you  finally